dr. Kersey you needed in trauma one dr.  Paul Kersey had the perfect life until  one fateful night but the law fails to  protect and serve while these are open  cases a up one man becomes a hero the  men who did it  are out there without wish I want to buy  a gun wish the man really wants to  protect what's his he has to do is for  himself  they're cocked locked and ready to work  I'll say  now this doctor is prescribing our  lethal dose of revenge kill me no jack  is directed by our master eli roth death  [Music]  starring bruce willis as judge jury and  executioner this isn't crazy weed this  guy in a hoodie derp calling the Grim  Reaper is he right for taking the law  into his own hands  he's become a folk hero you look much  better whatever you're doing keep it up  I will death wish  rated R in theaters March 2nd  you